>> PROTESTERS CAUSING CHAOS
AFTER BARGING INTO A
CITY COUNCIL MEETING AND
THREATENING LAWMAKERS.
THEY WERE ANGRY OVER A MEASURE
THAT WOULD BAN HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS NEAR SCHOOLS AND
DAY CARES.
POLICE WOUND UP ARRESTING TWO OF
THE ACTIVISTS.
THE BILL WOULD FURTHER ISOLATE
THE HOMELESS COMMUNITY AND
ULTIMATELY THE CITY COUNCIL THAT
WILL PAST A MEMBER.
JUDGE, I WANT TO COME TO YOU
FIRST.
WE ALL AGREE THAT VIOLENCE HAS
NO PLACE IN ANY OF THIS.
YOU NEED TO DISRUPT PEACEFULLY.
BUT WHAT YOU THINK OF THE
MEASURE ITSELF?
I'M TRENT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA BE POPPING UP IN
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
ARE DEALING WITH HOMELESS
PROBLEMS.
>> IF THEY BAN HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS NEAR SCHOOLS AND
NEAR DAY CARE CENTERS, I MEAN I
DON'T THINK IT'S ANYTHING WRONG
WITH THAT, OBVIOUSLY.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT CHILDREN IN
SCHOOL AND WE HAVE TO PROTECT
CHILDREN IN DAY CARE CENTERS
BEAR THE PROBLEM WITH THESE
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS, A LOT OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE DRUG USERS THAT
HAVE MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
THEY'VE GOT ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS.
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE OBJECTING
TO THE DISPLACEMENT, AS THEY
CALL IT.
THE DISPLACEMENT OF THE HOMELESS
AND THINK IT'S UNFAIR AND
ILLEGAL ARE TOTALLY WRONG.
THEY DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO PITCH
UP TENT IN A PUBLIC PLACE.
I THINK TENNESSEE HAS PASSED A
LAW THAT SAYS IF YOU PITCH A
TENT ON PUBLIC LAND IT'S A
FELONY FOR WHAT YOU GET SIX
YEARS OF PRISON.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING TO PUT THEM
IN PRISON FOR SIX YEARS, THEY
ARE LOOKING TO TAKE THEM TO THE
NEXT LEVEL, WHICH IS TO GET THE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT THEY
NEED.
>> WHAT ABOUT, DANA?
>> WHILE THIS HAS BEEN -- IT'S
VERY FRUSTRATING.
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
LOS ANGELES IS THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM.
IT AFFECTS EVERYBODY'S QUALITY
OF LIFE AND IT COMPACTS YOUR
COMPASSION.
YOU DON'T LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE IN
THE STREET LIKE THAT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS, THEY'RE
HAPPY WITH NO GUN ZONES, BUT
WHAT ABOUT NO HOMELESS OWNED UP
AROUND THE SCHOOL?
THAT SHOULD BE -- THE
CITY COUNCIL AGREED, THEY PASSED
IT.
THE OTHER THING HAPPENING IN
LOS ANGELES THAT'S GOING TO BE
ON THE BALLOT IN NOVEMBER, THEY
WANT TO MAKE HOTELS REPORT BY
2:00 P.M. WHAT ROOMS ARE STILL
AVAILABLE.
AND YOU HAVE TO DO THIS, THIS IS
MANDATED.
AND THEY WILL PUT HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN THOSE HOTEL ROOMS FOR
THE NIGHT.
YOU HAVE NO SAY ABOUT IT IF YOU
ARE THE HOTEL OWNER.
THAT IS SOMETHING THEY WANT
PEOPLE TO VOTE ON.
I HOPE PEOPLE COME OUT AND VOTE
ON THAT BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT
HAS AN OBLIGATION TO TRY TO HELP
THE PEOPLE.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE WILLING TO
HELP THE PEOPLE BUT THESE
SOLUTIONS ARE NOT GOING TO CUT
IT.
>> GREG, WHAT ABOUT THAT
PROGRAM?
LIKE THE BEVERLY HILLS HOTEL
ALSO HAS --
>> THERE IS A LOT OF UNSPEAKABLE
TRUTHS YOU CANNOT SAY ABOUT THIS
BUT YOU SHOULD SAY.
THEY ARE MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT FOR
YEARS.
WERE NOT GOING TO GET ANY SHAME
ABOUT THEY SHOULD BE BANNED
PERIOD.
THESE ARE NOT SAFE PLACES.
THESE ARE NOT MENTALLY ILL
PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
CHOOSE TO LIVE THERE.
AND IF YOU SAY -- BELIEVE ME
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS THE WAY TO
LIVE.
I SEE THEM, I WALKED BY THEM, I
KNOW THEM ALMOST BY NAME BECAUSE
I WALKED BY THEM ON
FIFTH AVENUE.
THEY LIKE PLACES WHERE THEY CAN
AGGRESSIVELY PANHANDLE.
THEY NEED TO BE IN THE CITY TO
SUPPORT THEIR LIFESTYLE.
THEY DO A LOT OF OUTDOOR
RECREATIONAL DRUG USE.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER HAS BEEN
COVERING THIS FOREVER.
HE RAN FOR GOVERNOR.
THE FACT IS BY CONFLATING THIS
WITH THE MENTALLY ILL, WHICH I
USED TO DO BUT NOW I SEE IT AS A
SEPARATE THING.
IT HURTS THE ABILITY TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
IN THOSE ENCAMPMENTS PEOPLE ARE
BEING ABUSED, THERE ARE PHYSICAL
FIGHTS, VIOLENT FIGHTS WITH
ACTUAL WEAPONS.
IT'S TRULY A DYSTOPIA AND ITS
NEAR HOLLYWOOD WHO PREFERS THEIR
DYSTOPIAN'S TO BE THE HANDMAID'S
TALE, THESE WHITE PATRIARCH
FANTASIES WENT JUST ON THE ROAD
DOWNTOWN IT IS SO BAD AND IT'S
EXPANDING AND EXPANDING IT IS
TIME TO BAN URBAN CAMPING,
RIGHT?
THEY'RE ONLY THERE BECAUSE THEY
CAN BE THERE.
>> WHY DO LIBERALS WANT HOMELESS
NEXT TO KIDS?
THAT'S WEIRD.
WHY ARE THEY PROTESTING TO PUT
HOMELESS PEOPLE HALF NAKED
CHEWED OF DRUGS IN FRONT OF A
NURSING SCHOOL?
WHY WOULD YOU WANT THAT?
WE USED TO HAVE REAL PROTEST
MOVEMENTS.
THEY PROTEST FOR CIVIL RIGHTS,
WOMEN'S RIGHTS, THERE IS NOTHING
LEFT TO PROTEST.
THEY ARE PROTESTING FOR THE
ABILITY OF HOMELESS PEOPLE TO
SMOKE CRACK IN FRONT OF A
NURSERY SCHOOL.
THAT IS INSANE.
IF YOU WANT TO PROTEST, FINE.
BUT YOU HAVE TO MOVE FROM THE
PROTEST TO PRODUCING SOMETHING.
IF YOU ARE STUCK ON HOMELESS,
OKAY.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY PROTESTING FOR
THE HOMELESS TO STAY HOMELESS.
THEY ARE NOT PRODUCING ANYTHING
FOR THE HOMELESS LIKE GETTING
THEM UP THE STREETS.
THEY ARE LIKE WE WANT THE
HOMELESS TO STAY SECOND
HOMELESS.
WE WANT THAT.
DON'T TRY TO STOP THEM FROM
LIVING A DEPRAVED UNHEALTHY LIFE
NEXT TO CHILDREN.
>> I THINK SOME DIGNIFIED
SOLUTION THAT TREATS PEOPLE WITH
RESPECT --
>> IS THERE ANY DIGNITY YOU SEE
ON THE STREETS?
IT'S THE LEAST DIGNIFIED THING
TO DO.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT A SOLUTION
THAT TREATS PEOPLE AS PEOPLE.
I'M JUST ADDING.
BOOZE -- TREATING THEM LIKE
PEOPLE IS GETTING THEM OFF THE
STREET AND GETTING THEM
TREATMENT.
>> WHY